every sale is the same right well why
because we take control we make it the
same we take immediate control of the
sale and you have four seconds to do it
that's it you are being judged in those
first four seconds your prospector lays
eyes on you they see you they rip you
apart they put you back together they've
judged each piece and based on that they
say to themselves even this person is
number one sharpest attack they're sharp
on the ball number two they're
enthusiastic what they have must be good
they seem enthusiastic about it and
number three most important of all and
expert in your field hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I want to
wake up every single day and get pushed
by somebody who's doing a lot more than
me and then watching their videos it
inspires me to be older to have more
courage and go chase down the life of my
dreams and I hope it does the same for
you so today let's learn the 7 sales
techniques to sell anything
enjoy
number one you must be perceived as
being sharp as attack you're sharp
you're on the ball you're a born problem
solver number two your enthusiastic as
hell
enthusiastic as hell meaning what you
have must be good now I'm not talking
about that bull over the top oh my God
that's that's over the top nonsense
enthusiasm it's not what I mean I'm
talking about something called bottled
enthusiasm it could be a whisper it's
beneath the service but it's palpable
it's strong and lastly and most
important of all
you are an expert in your field
sharpest attack enthusiasts have an
expert in your field meaning that you
are someone that knows theirs
you are an expert and what do we do when
we're in the position or in the presence
of experts what do we do we defer
we've been trained since we're yay big
to defer to experts when we're very
young our parents took us to the doctor
when we're sick right and even our own
parents went before we're like wow this
is a very special guys but the school
the doctor would ask us questions you
could answer we don't interrupt them
when we are in presence of experts we
defer you must be perceived as sharp as
attack
enthusiastic as hell an expert in your
field
if you're not perceived this way what
happens the prospect tries to take
control when we believe that we're
dealing with a novice someone who's dull
not enthusiastic we will take control
and what I realized that first night I
invented the straight line back in 1988
believe it or not this is what I
realized I had a certain way of talking
a certain way of ethnic commanded
Authority people knew they were in the
presence of an expert and because of
that they would defer to me I was able
to take control of the conversation and
once I had control
I could then make every sale this and I
could follow a certain road map to
closing everyone using the same
technique if the prospect is in control
how could you do that
you can't use any technique because
you're you don't know what's coming next
the first step
in What's called the straight line
syntax is you must take immediate
control of the sale
you must take control because what's
really happening
in the mind of the Prospect and it
happens in those first four seconds they
say
this is a person worth listening to
that's what this chunks up and say you
know what he's show up enthusiasts she's
sharp enthusiastic expert they are worth
listening to because he or she can help
me achieve my goals
they can help me get what I want that's
why people listen to you
we seek out experts to solve all
problems eliminate our opinion you must
be perceived this way when you are what
happens they defer so watch number one
you got four seconds
you sound you must sound this way
there's something you must be perceived
the prospect says wow this person's an
expert in their field a shop wow
they probably could help me get what I
want they're experts I've been taught
that is respectful to defer to an expert
so now that gives you the opportunity to
take control you then take control and
you use that to start asking questions
and you ask those questions in a very
specific way using certain tonalities
and you start building massive Rapport
that way technique number two is give
value with Grant Cardone you've sold
billions of dollars in Revenue
throughout your career you know how have
you been able to consistently close
massive deals what is Grant cardone's
secret to sales eighty percent of
everything we do here
it's free now the 20 to pay me you know
this year will pay me 150 million
dollars
but the 80 percent got got a billion
dollars worth of advice they just didn't
pay me anything but they came into my
funnel right they came into my okay now
I know who they are can I serve them
when they're ready to pay something not
everybody's ready to pay right so like
when I was a kid man I I wouldn't pay
for anything because they didn't have
any money
so if if I went you know if you walk
into a casino in Vegas you can walk in
you don't have to have money
all you got to do is walk in
everything's free so in my world I'm a
big open Casino like everything's free
now when you get in you're like you know
I'd like to sit at that table with the
whales well then that caught something
or I want to sit over this table with
the hundred dollar player sir I want to
go over here and play this game well to
do that then you got to sit down you got
to pay so we've raised 1.1 billion
dollars crowdfunding on the internet
I don't go to wealthy people I don't go
to Mark Cuban and say hey fund my
project I've never gone to a big
um Equity Fund like a Blackstone and say
give me a billion dollars I could but I
don't I go to I build a big audience
I create great products and offers and
then I go to that always say would you
guys like to invest with me
so out of we I think we have 450 000
people in an investor uh that raised
their hand and said I'm interested in
your Investments thirteen thousand of
the four hundred thousand invested with
me you need to change your mind about
closing people closing people is when
you service them for the first time you
guys need to understand that when you
close a deal when somebody actually buys
your product service
offer whatever your offer is that's when
you finally service them I don't think
about the clothes being I got you I got
you uh you know I don't think about it
being that and I think a lot of sales
people think oh I got you you know no I
didn't get you dude I finally
I finally serviced you when I closed you
by the way that should be the first
close that should be of the 154 000
people that bought something for me last
year
45 000 of them have bought three four
five six seven eight things like thirty
percent of our and I want to get the
other seventy percent to make sure
that's not the first thing and the only
thing they buy from you technique number
three is build trust with vusi tembaqueo
how do you sell anything to anyone for
those of you watching this wondering why
you care because life is sales you sell
yourself to your partner you sell
yourself to your children you sell
yourself at your job you sell yourself
to your boss you sell yourself to your
clients all of us are constantly selling
especially those of you that think
you're not and there's one way to sell
anything to anybody
it's the oldest trick in the book and
it's not a trick it's a way of living
your life
build trust how do you build trust
commit to something deliver on it
communicate effectively and make sure
that everything you say you're going to
do you do and if you can't that you
communicate up front this is an age-old
wisdom it's probably not going to Trend
this video you're not going to share it
a million times with your friends
because it sounds common sense you know
the crazy thing about living in the
world in 2023 is the common things are
just not so common anymore you want to
stand out build trust do the simple
things really really well
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free work
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there technique number four is believe
in what you're selling with garyvee
listen at the end of the day
vanity metrics whether that's followers
on Instagram whether that's the jewelry
or car you drive no matter what it is at
the end of the day underneath all of
that there needs to be something
tangible and real and if you're not
asking for business and more importantly
if you're not selling something you
believe in you're finished the single
reason I think I'm a great salesman as
somebody who hates to ask for a sale is
because I deeply believe in what I'm
selling whether it's the wine I produce
whether it's a sneaker collaboration I
have with K-Swiss whether it's Vayner I
I sit in this do you know what it feels
like to sit in this room and know
think no that vaynermedia is the best
marketing firm in the world it's it's
empowering you you sell with conviction
and I just watch way too many people uh
either be deeply insecure about what
they're selling Because deep down they
know they have no idea what the
they're selling that's right yeah or
they're just broken they just so care
about money they know exactly what
they're selling they just know they're
selling and they're preying on
people's fears and I want to kill those
technique number five is aim to help
with Mark Cuban if you come up with an
idea where you say I can make dollar
bills for 50 cents would you go out and
raise money or would you just go out and
sell it
you just go out and do it you know and
and that's what you have to do and look
we all go through that fear factor of do
I quit my job do I can I do this
um can I can I do this and what happens
next the one thing I I know with 100
certainty and what I would tell myself
is
if I can sell
and become a better and better
salesperson and be great at selling
I'm always going to be successful
whether I'm working for myself
or if the company that I started just
didn't work I'll give you an example
um out of Indiana before I went down to
Dallas I needed to start something and
um I decided that everybody drank milk
and I found this product powdered milk
that was cheaper and everybody needed to
save money and I was going to go out
there and sell it
um because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good yeah
and so what I've but I went out there to
try to sell it
failed miserably but I learned
how to make the sales effort even when
things weren't going right I learned
that the rejection was every no got me
closer to a yes that not every product
was perfect but I could take those same
skills even in failure and translate
them so that what I learned selling
garbage bags door to door what I learned
from selling powdered milk that was
awful what I learned from selling local
area networks at micro Solutions all
those things
accumulated and I I got better at
selling so I always knew you know people
always say to me if you lost everything
what would you do
I can sell
I can sell and it's not about selling
ice to Eskimos it's not about you know
convincing people to do this selling is
always about helping selling is always
about understanding the person you're
talking to and what their needs are and
if someone can help me
make my life easier yeah people you know
now with employees people always say
well like what's the definition of a
great employee
someone who can reduce the stress of
those around them and it's the same
thing what's the definition of a great
salesperson someone who can reduce the
stress of their sales people and if in
looking at your company and looking at
your your life and looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize that
whether it works or doesn't work you're
putting yourself in a position where
you're helping somebody not convincing
somebody but and you're reducing their
stress
you're gonna you're gonna be okay it's
gonna work out and you know that's the
confidence I I've built in myself that
wasn't necessarily always there
um
but I learned that if I try to help if I
reduce people's stress good things can
happen technique number six is be honest
with Layla hermosi when you're first
starting off in business you don't need
to think sales like am I building a
giant sales department a sales or you
just need to figure out can you sell
because in the beginning the best sales
person is actually the founder in the
beginning of every business that Alex
and I started we were the first
salespeople and athens.com that means we
were the first ones that were closing
the first deals it is one of the most
Paramount pieces of the business because
it is the bridge between the marketing
and the back end you learn so much about
the customer through doing sales that I
think you would be doing yourself a
disservice in the beginning by not doing
this starting out the more people that
you talk to and have sales conversations
with the more people that you understand
who is a fit for my product or service
and who isn't because a lot of the times
people think oh I just can't sell but it
might actually be that you're trying to
sell to the wrong people it was the
first skill that I understood personally
in our businesses and because of it I
was able to learn so many other skills
because I had that Foundation I think
that the best way to get better at sales
when you're first starting off is to
stop labeling it as sales I didn't read
a ton of books on sales and I didn't
know a lot about sales before I started
doing sales I was told that I was just
signing somebody up for a gym through
that process of signing somebody up I
think it relieved a lot of pressure it's
not convincing people it's not coercing
people it's just showing them you want
this I have this
their match the best way to sell is just
be honest with people to tell the truth
and state the facts about what you
provide about what you do and about
who's best for your product or service
and technique number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
shift your thinking with Robert Kiyosaki
I made so many people and say well I
can't afford this I can't afford that I
can't afford to buy real estate I can't
afford to buy Bitcoin I can't afford to
buy well there is you can't afford to
buy something is because you can't sell
and sales equals income
so back in 1974
you know my my dad wanted me to go to
the University of Hawaii and get my PhD
and I said no I'm gonna well he wanted
to fly for the airlines because of the
pilot and I said no I'm not going to do
that I'm going to learn how to sell
and it was he was up my he was upset
he said you know salesman is a sales
amount of Crux they're con artists you
know it's not it's not a very honorable
profession but that's why he was poor
you know so many PhD types academic
types
they think they're above the capitalist
process process
they think they're PhD entitles them
to the better life
but if you go for your PhD you really
don't have the skill sets
to be in the capitalist world
you know like when my my father you know
blessed his heart he ran for lieutenant
governor against his boss the governor
as a republican in the People's Republic
of Hawaii you know Hawaii's 100
communist
and um so he ran as a Republican
and he lost
and the governor said to him you'll
never work in this state again
so the power the governor had over my
dad was his job
and the hardest thing for a school
teacher Patrick
is you as a capitalist you really don't
need a school teacher you need a
Salesman
and my father just couldn't sell he
wouldn't you know he just kept holding
up his PhD I have a PhD
but he couldn't sell wow and you know
what I mean and and I saw that
and that's when my uh Rich Dad who had
no education at all said um you better
learn how to sell pretty quickly
making a product that people love starts
with you making something that you love
really think about it would you buy from
you would you subscribe to you would you
comment and tell your friends about you
in our rush to get rich to make money we
push products out that we don't love and
if you don't love them people around you
won't love them either so look at my
YouTube channel as an example I love my
YouTube channel I make my YouTube
channel for myself I learn it's selfish
it's for me the top 10 rules videos the
espresso videos the content that I bring
together I need it it's my education I
love my channel I would share my Channel
with other people if I saw my channel
and I wasn't creating I'd be the first
thing that I subscribed to it would be
much watch YouTube for me I need it and
if you guys didn't like it I would still
create it for myself I wouldn't have as
much editing and fancy effects and all
that stuff but I would still do it
because I need it for me I make it for
myself selfishly and then I share it
with you guys and thankfully you guys
like it enough that I can turn a
business from it and continue to hire
team and create more content and pump
more stuff out but as much as I think
that my channel still needs to get
better and grow and improve and I still
suck and I need to continuously get
better at the work that I do I think my
channel deserves a Nobel Peace Prize
like I think my channel is amazing
and you have to love what you do you
have to feel like the thing that you're
doing yes can always get better but it's
really solving a problem
your product your service what you
create your expertise solves a problem
you know that it's genuinely helping
people if you don't have that belief
you're never gonna win this is why so
many people who are starting businesses
when you go and you look at hot business
trends for 2019 or 2020 or
how to win in network marketing and like
what products I should sell if that's
how you're starting you're going to lose
if you're just chasing trains you will
lose there's nothing wrong with network
marketing per se just most of the people
getting into it are just trying to make
a buck just like how most people get
into entrepreneurship you're just trying
to make money too many people and then
you end up going broke because the
people who love doing that thing will
crush you every day of the week think
about who you're going up against you're
going up against people in whatever
industry you're in you're going up
against people who have experience who
have expertise who have knowledge and
love the thing that they're doing and
you're gonna go in because it's a hot
trend for this year and expect to win oh
now if you love it
and you absorb it and it's it's for you
and it's must have you will pour so much
energy so much love so much creativity
and find the PATH nobody else has seen
before that's how you ultimately win
that's how you can then start talking
about it start promoting it start
building exposure get in Word of Mouth
if you want people to talk about you you
have to create something that is worth
talking about and there's no way that
you create it unless you absolutely love
the thing that you're doing so you have
to create a product or service that you
would use yourself you have to create a
channel that you would subscribe to
yourself you have to feel confident that
if your mom was suffering with a problem
that your business could solve that you
would recommend it 100 to your mom
if my mom was struggling with
entrepreneurship you need to subscribe
to my channel it will help you it will
save you
if you can't be like that yet go back
make it better until you find something
that you absolutely love and pour your
energy into so I'm gonna give you a
three-step process you can follow to
help you evaluate where you're at and
how you can get better step number one
get out of your space
wherever you're at right now wherever
you're working you're in front of your
computer you're at your office you're
your home your basement whatever
wherever you normally work wherever you
are right now get out of your space just
get out of your typical space go outside
for a walk go down to the lobby cross
the street whatever get outside your
typical space okay step number two now
that you're in a different space think
about your customers think about who you
are helping think about the problem that
you solve so if it's me I can go for a
walk outside I'm thinking about
entrepreneurs I'm gonna have my space
it's too easy to get locked into what
what I'm doing right I gotta make I
gotta make 20 videos today I gotta
respond the comments I gotta connect
with my team I gotta learn all the stuff
adds up and forget about our customers
so I go outside and think about
entrepreneurs and I try to picture the
people that I've helped the people
who've come to my Workshops the people
who ask me questions that people will
join me on lives right close your eyes
you're in a new space now and you think
about your customers think about the
people who you help the people that you
are designing your products and services
for think about them picture them try to
pick or somebody right picture an
individual that you know that you are
trying to help picture that person in
your mind and if you don't have a
customer yet think about the ideal
customers that you're trying to Target
and try to come up with a face somebody
that you can look at and in Step number
three go back to where you were go back
to your office your computer wherever
you were with that person in mind and
then evaluate your products
with that person in mind look at your
YouTube videos look at your products
look at your services look at your
Instagram feed whatever you're trying to
get out there look at your books look at
your books
whatever you're trying to promote look
at them with that person in mind now
you've stepped outside your day to day
you're above you're not in the in the
muck of doing all the work I know you've
got tons of stuff to do you're an
entrepreneur I feel you you've stepped
outside you've imagined that person
you're coming back and looking at your
products and services with fresh eyes
with them in mind
do they actually need it will this
change their life will this solve their
problems
and if not
go make it better when it comes to an
affirmation affirmations can be powerful
uh
and for some people they're not and a
lot of people say well you know if the
the affirmation is so powerful how come
I'm not experiencing the effect
the what scientists tell us is the
average human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day
some of those thoughts are the words to
the songs and they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift the very core of our expression
so we know that words are are powerful
the key to a successful affirmation is
that we must communicate with the
subconscious part of our of our mind
number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said did they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted
from the texts leaving us with a sense
that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you are a victim you need
a savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility uh as a sovereign biological
being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing uh nor is it ever yeah
faster than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's subtle and it's powerful it's
not making something happen out there
and that means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we began as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and they'll also gave me the reason to
test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't I know you
all have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do you've got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create contribute
to give to be an awesome human being but
all of that is impossible without great
habits set up if you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way that will
keep you on track then you'll you'll
fall off and and having new goals
without new habits is kind of like you
know having a new car without wheels you
know the habits are the wheels they are
the things that make you able to achieve
the goals so you got to have good habits
but the challenge for most people isn't
that knowledge I mean you know you need
to have good habits it's you can't keep
the Habit going right have you ever
started it the new year you're going to
get healthier and you start that habit
of working out on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision in your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in
day-to-day life it's not enough you need
things to trigger you to remind you to
be that particular kind of person right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long to tell you what to do and how
to be you'd obviously become better well
that makes sense well let's use that
idea let's use that idea by setting up
alarms on our phones that trigger us to
do the very things we need to do this
can be so basic you're going to laugh
and then also tell you how I literally
taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they
said it was the one thing that changed
their life the most dramatically so
let's start with this let's have a goal
in mind let's say you want to become
more present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you can meditate in the morning say
today don't be more present and calm and
you could you could start out with good
intentions but those fall apart without
a trigger moment set up throughout the
day to remind you that so what if you
did this what if you just set up on your
phone three alarms during the day with a
label that said
close your eyes
[Music]
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths
and then again it happens at two o'clock
and again it happens at 6 p.m and again
it happens at 8pm
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that 50
minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I'm
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I haven't so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach Executives to do this as
well I have them have a door frame
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame they have boom
three words go through their mind about
how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
that think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
one of the things that will help you to
do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about so for those of you that
have read the high five habit one of the
things that I talk about a lot is every
single day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind to filter the world
differently just like you woke up and
you saw the date Day 2 22 22 and your
brain saw that was like whoa this is a
once in a lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called the
reticular activating system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there I talk to so many
smart fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and I'll ask them how's it going
and they'll say I think I'm gonna quit
and I'm like why they say to me I'm not
making an impact I'm like you know
you've been here eight months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
Millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was Mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you
find Joy from is not something you
discover it's not like I Found Love
here it is I found a job I love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
Joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump it on to the next ghost
and on to the next and by the way
ghosting
means the lack of skill to have a
confrontation
you date somebody for six months eight
months
and then just stop replying
just delete them from everything
now for the person who's doing the
ghosting oh that's certainly easier than
a confrontation but the person on the
receiving end of the ghosting it's like
there's a death there's suddenly shunned
there's Panic they call out they're
worrying they call out their word they
think it's you they think it's them do
you have any idea the destruction that
we reap on people by ghosting them
and then because there's the lack of
social skills to call out and ask for
help they internalize and it makes them
feel awful to the point at the worst
they will kill themselves slightly one
level down they'll get depressed but the
lowest level that we can hope for is
they will go through life and I'm not
talking about ghosting I'm talking an
entire generation that if we don't fix
this we'll go through life where
everything's just fine my friendships
are fine my work is fine you know same
old same old nothing's ever amazing
and the scavenger hunt continues
and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them
environment
we're taking a generation that has lower
self-esteem we're taking a generation
that has a lack of coping mechanisms to
deal with stress we're dealing with a
generation that wants all those things
fixed immediately and we're placing them
in work environments that values money
more than people
do you know that most of the business
philosophies most of the business
theories that we Embrace and see as
standard today are not standard there
are theories left over from the 80s and
90s
the concept of shareholder Supremacy was
a theory proposed in the late 1970s it
was popularized in the 80s and 90s
the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s
it did not exist
it became popular in the 80s and 90s
the 80s and 90s were boom years
anyone could make money relative peace a
Kinder gentle or cold war and so all of
the business theories that were put
forth were very very selfish and all
about enriching ourselves
and they worked for those times but
these times are different these are not
peaceful times
these are not boom years this is there's
globalization in the internet which has
now made everything vastly more
complicated and those theories do not
work anymore worse they're having side
effects
it's really bad because what we do is we
destroy corporate cultures
the idea of using mass layoffs can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry
I can no longer provide for our family
because the company missed its arbitrary
projections this year
that's what we're doing that's like a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players hoping to
build a great team
it doesn't work we dismantled things
like the glass-steagall Act
glass-steagall was passed after the
Great Depression to prevent another
Great Depression from happening it would
dismantled in the 80s and the 90s in the
name of a prophet
okay do you know how many stock market
crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of
glass-steagall
the answer is
zero
and since they dismantled glass-steagall
we had 87 the.com crash 2008. we've had
three stock market crashes because we've
moved the safety mechanisms that prevent
stock market crashes from happening all
in the name of individual advancement
and profit and these are the corporate
cultures we've built
corporate cultures that value numbers
over people and they are not standard
business practices they are new and they
are broken and they are dangerous and
we're asking a young wonderful ambitious
amazing generation that needs us to work
in these environments
whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for the
bad hand that you've been dealt
it is up to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence
it is up to the companies to create an
environment
in which you can learn coping mechanisms
and learn how to build strong close
relationships with people with whom you
work that you will eventually love and
sacrifice to see that they gain
it is in these environments that we will
learn the patience and the hard work
that it takes to find fulfillment in our
lives to find a sense of purpose a sense
of joy
yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older Generations say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders now
we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments now
and we're making your lives worse
I don't want you to jump from job to job
to job to job you will never find what
you're looking for it's not a scavenger
hunt I don't want you to go from
relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you properly
nobody wants to wake up in the morning
and be managed we want to wake up in the
morning and be led and we have a total
leadership crisis in America politics is
just the mirror reflection we get the
politicians we deserve
We're The Divided ones we're the selfish
ones we're the broken ones we're the
ones who would sooner sacrifice somebody
else so that we may gain it's us
and until we're willing to do the hard
work of repairing the world around us
our country our politics our businesses
will not fix
[Music]
because you made a this far in a video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the 10 sales techniques that can make
you rich check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you can't influence you can't
persuade good luck trying to get your
business off the ground I'm not talking
about just your customers I'm talking
about the bankers the people of venture
capitalists your vendors your credit
card processor the people who work for
you